[Musique]
merci
fête étrangère compliquée
bonjour bonjour
oui c'est la nuit désolé
oh mon Dieu je
pleure
ça ressemble à une cabane enflammée
ouais
c'est très unique oui oui d'
abord les choses s'accrochent à l'
étranger
un style de vie c'est comme ça qu'on est  comme on l'a
toujours fait on invite toujours des gens on
a toujours une maison pleine d'amis on a
toujours
euh
la maison est toujours bruyante et pleine d'
amour alors oui
tu sais je crois que j'étais française dans une vie antérieure
euh
et mais tu sais aussi je suis tombée dedans  l'amour
avec des amis à travers Monex Mahi,
vraiment euh il m'a montré le meilleur de
ce qu'est ce pays
et euh alors c'était j'ai eu une
histoire d'amour avec euh la France depuis très
longtemps A La France
à
euh
[Musique]
ouais parce que  si vous les avez au Mexique,
vous mourrez parce qu'ils sont si chauds,
euh,
j'ai grandi avec ce euh produit et
je n'ai jamais connu l'histoire
du concierge mexicain qui
l'a inventé et donc quand j'ai trouvé
cette histoire, je suis devenu  obsédé et j'étais
comme je devais je dois
raconter son histoire
ok j'adore
regarder la vérité qu'est-ce que
ça brûle arrêtons de
se manger j'aime ça c'était bien j'avais
cherché une réponse
et voilà
ils étaient là tout le temps  la fois où
tu es une bonne idée, c'est un camp épicé,
ça va tout changer, cela
sauvera notre usine et tu es un concierge,
découvre la prochaine étape, vois que le
marché hispanique ne sera pas ignoré, le
marché hispanique ne sera pas ignoré, bien,
mais dans ton  voix,
nous perdons du temps avec cette
idée folle des concierges, les gars comme vous me veulent, nous
n'avons pas de photos comme celle-ci, vous voyez ce
type juste là, je vois un chingon Montana, de l'
argent
[Musique] [
Musique]
J'ai un petit Hood là-bas à la  fin mais
[Musique]
oui oui et bien il est mexicain-américain comme
moi je suis mexicain-américain et
euh
nous avons une expérience très unique aux
États-Unis euh parce que parfois
tu sais aux États-Unis, ils sont
comme oh tu es mexicain  et puis quand nous
allons au Mexique, ils disent oh tu es l'
Américain et donc nous ne sommes jamais
vraiment à notre place nulle part et donc j'ai vraiment
senti
que je pouvais m'identifier à ça,
mais aussi à son dynamisme et à sa
persévérance.  et sa ténacité, je veux dire,
il a vraiment
eu
beaucoup moins de succès
et donc accomplir quelque chose comme ça
est euh, c'est une source d'inspiration pour beaucoup de gens qui
pensent  genre oh tu sais j'ai tellement d'
obstacles dans ma vie je ne peux pas faire ça et
puis ils regardent ce film ils se disent wow
si ce type l'a fait je je suis sûr que je peux faire
n'importe quoi grave
euh je suis très efficace je euh toi  je sais ce que
j'ai commencé à réaliser il y a environ 10 ans
et j'ai découvert que
j'étais Je suis naturel J'aime vraiment ça Je
me sens très à l'aise derrière la caméra Je
connais très bien J'en savais plus que
ce que j'avais l'impression de savoir j'étais comme oh  Je
sais ça
euh je suis un bon conteur
euh je pense que tu sais quand tu vois
flamboyant c'est ma personnalité parce que c'est
drôle c'est énergique c'est touchant ça
tire le cœur c'est émotif c'est
inspirant ça a du rythme ça bouge et
donc quand à chaque fois si tu vraiment  connais-moi
et tu vois le film les gens y vont oh mon
Dieu c'est tellement Eva comme le film En
général, le ton général
c'est moi bonjour
ils étaient incroyables la première fois dans l'
histoire de la Maison Blanche qu'un
film sur  Les Latinos ont été montrés et
projetés euh c'était je le suis toujours, je
n'arrive toujours pas à y croire, ils ont illuminé toute la
Maison Blanche comme un Cheeto
euh et il y avait des milliers de Latinos sur la
pelouse de la maison du peuple qui est la
Maison Blanche et des gens qui pleuraient  pleuraient
parce qu'ils se sentaient vus et faisaient
partie du pays et souvent les
Latinos ne se sentent pas partie des
États-Unis et
euh vous savez, nous nous sentons souvent marginalisés,
donc vous savez, être accueillis de cette façon
et célébrés à l'écran aussi  C'était
un moment que je n'oublierai jamais mais
oui, je veux dire, tu sais, Biden a beaucoup parlé
du rêve américain et à quel point il
aimait l'histoire de Richard, il connaît
Richard Montanez et il pensait que vous savez,
c'est un excellent
exemple de l'opportunité que vous connaissez.
notre pays a à offrir donc je pense qu'il a
été très inspiré par le film
euh
je peux manger ça avec deux bons conseils
mexicains
et c'est y'a comme des macarons et du
guacamole
oh mon Dieu
d'abord deboi c'est mon préféré je déteste qu'ils
ne soient que de saison  pendant très
peu de temps,
c'est
tellement heureux,
excusez-moi.
Tacos aux haricots Les tacos aux haricots sont mon petit-
déjeuner quotidien mais pas en France
en France j'ai une omelette française
comme comment pouvez-vous ne pas être en France et
ne pas avoir de franchise
oui par  loin,
je veux dire, en fait, c'est entre la
cuisine et mon placard mais pour la
plupart c'est ma cuisine ouais c'est sûr oh
mon Dieu il y a du fromage oui bien sûr
c'est comme du deboi frais et du fromage de
France mais euh si j'étais à la maison si je  j'étais à
la maison et j'ai préparé le dîner c'est généralement de la
nourriture mexicaine c'est toujours de la nourriture mexicaine
et c'est généralement des tacos Je fais généralement
différents un bar à tacos entier et je fais des
tacos au poulet et des tacos au bœuf et des tacos aux légumes
et j'ai du guacamole et de la salsa et
tout ça donc  ouais, c'est mon
plat habituel que je sers ou que je prépare
mm-hmm
ouais je le suis,
j'ai grandi dans un ranch et donc mon père
ne nous laissait pas manger dehors comme si nous ne pouvions pas
manger de fast-food ou si nous n'avions jamais mangé au
restaurant
euh, il a dit que tout ce dont nous avons besoin est ici
et que vous mangez de l'agneau, donc si c'était
comme la saison des courges, nous aurions des courges
pendant des mois et je dirais que je déteste les courges, puis
ce serait la saison des pastèques
et nous devrions manger  tellement que comme si
nous mangions toujours de façon saisonnière et
euh
et nous ne l'étions jamais vraiment, nous n'avons jamais vraiment mangé à l'extérieur,
alors cuisiner et être dans la cuisine avec des
ingrédients naturels, c'est comme ça que
j'ai grandi, sauf parfois une fois par
mois quand ma mère a eu  payée, elle
nous chercherait une Domino's Pizza le vendredi
et nous mangerions la pizza et nous devions
jeter les cartons de pizza à
la poubelle de mon voisin pour que mon père ne
voie pas les cartons
étrangers
là-bas,
je ne sais pas  si je veux voir ça,
oh mon Dieu, j'ai l'impression d'avoir l'air plus vieux là-bas
que maintenant, comme qu'est-ce que j'étais, c'était, c'était,
je viens du Texas, donc au
Texas, nous aimons les gros cheveux, les gros cheveux et beaucoup
de maquillage et donc c'était  c'était que c'était
moi toi c'est en noir et blanc
mais si c'était en couleur c'est
le rouge à lèvres le plus rouge que tu aies jamais vu
et mes cheveux on les taquinerait vraiment en gros
pour les concours
oh mon Dieu c'est
oui parce que dans
tout d'abord, juste avant ça, j'étais
en dernière année d'université
et
je n'avais plus d'argent comme si mon
aide financière était épuisée, tout était épuisé mes
parents ne payaient pas pour l'université comme si
ce n'était tout simplement pas possible
euh et
je me souviens de ma petite amie  disant
bonjour, tu devrais participer à ce concours de bourses
parce que tu peux gagner de l'argent pour l'école et
je me disais : ok, qu'est-ce que c'est, que
dois-je faire, c'est comme une page de beauté Je n'ai
jamais participé à un concours de beauté J'ai grandi
sous le nom de La Prieta FEA  qui est le plus laid et sombre
et j'étais comme d'accord et j'ai regardé les
prix et j'ai vu que la quatrième place était
euh comme des livres, ils paieraient pour mes
livres et j'ai dit d'accord si je pouvais juste
obtenir la quatrième place et ensuite si j'obtenais quatre
emplois  comme si j'essayais de comprendre comment
je pouvais me permettre de terminer mes études
universitaires et euh et
j'ai fini par gagner celui-là et donc j'ai
gagné celui-là et je me dis oh mon Dieu, je
ne peux pas le croire et donc j'ai payé pour
l'université mais parce que j'ai gagné celui-là, ils
vont bien, tu dois aller au suivant
et j'étais comme oh non non, je ne veux pas, je ne veux pas
continuer, alors j'ai dû
entrer à Miss Corpus Christi et ensuite j'ai gagné
Miss Corpus Christi et ensuite ils se sont
dit, ok, maintenant tu dois aller à Miss
Texas. J'étais comme si je ne voulais pas, je ne veux pas
être une fille de concours, j'avais juste besoin d'argent
pour l'université, donc c'était
euh dans ce package de prix, c'était un  voyage à
Los Angeles et celui-ci était spécial
parce que j'ai grandi à Corpus Christi donc
être Miss Corpus Christi était comme une grosse
affaire
euh et euh
ouais et je suis allé à Los Angeles et je ne suis jamais rentré
ici nous sommes
désolés
j'étais comme si de rien n'était  ça arrive oh c'est
bon pour les femmes au foyer moi,
qu'est-ce que tu fais oh je t'aide à faire tes
valises, pense à tout l'argent que
tu vas économiser sur du papier bulle
sais-tu
sais-tu combien je valais quand nous nous sommes
rencontrés j'étais sur  la couverture des magazines, j'avais
une carrière et un avenir mais j'ai
tout abandonné pour toi et qu'est-ce qu'on m'a
rendu
si tu casses encore une chose alors aide-moi,
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
[Musique]
c'est
tout oh  J'adore être la
sortie de Gabby, Gabby me manque, être en elle
dans ses chaussures dans ses tenues me manque,
euh ouais, c'était assez révolutionnaire et
j'étais si jeune, j'étais un bébé, je regarde
ça et je me demande pourquoi ma voix sonne
comme ça
euh mais oui, c'était le cas, je me souviens avoir lu
le pilote et je pensais que oh, c'est tellement
différent que ça ne réussira jamais, ça
ne sera jamais repris et je n'aurais jamais
imaginé que 10 ans de ma vie seraient
consacrés à cette série et à Gabby
à Gabby's  mais j'ai adoré, j'ai adoré chaque
minute
de la série, les filles et l'
écriture et nous nous sommes tellement amusés que c'était
une période vraiment amusante de ma vie,
oh, je dis toujours que je suis le premier
à signer  pour euh un
redémarrage ou un spin-off mais
euh personne ne veut le faire, ils se sentent
surtout l'écrivain le créateur de
Mark Jerry a vraiment l'impression qu'il
n'y a plus rien à dire vous savez, nous avons
fait une décennie de cette série 24 épisodes
a  l'année c'était beaucoup l'année prochaine ça
fera 20 ans 2024 ça fera 20 ans d'accord
[Musique] [
Musique]
ne devrais-je pas être celui qui
s'infiltre en tant que femme de chambre, cela ne serait-il pas
mieux non non cette histoire ne parle pas  toi, c'est
à propos des copains, c'est à propos de
l'autonomisation des Latinas, soutiens-moi ici Eva,
je ne sais pas, est-ce que tous les copains doivent être
latinos, cela semble un peu raciste non, ce n'est pas
toutes les femmes de chambre qui sont latines, mais ces femmes de chambre le
sont si nous changeons de race.  de la
servante assassinée, nous pouvons trouver quelqu'un de meilleur
qu'Eva, ok, c'est tout, je suis parti
[Musique]
au fait, tu es la personne la plus méchante que j'ai
jamais rencontrée
[Applaudissements]
saison des médicaments sidibus Épisode de chat oui,
eh bien, il a été créé par Mark Cherry
euh  qui a créé Desperate Housewives, c'était
juste après la fin du bureau désespéré
et
euh, c'était tellement intelligent, c'était une
série vraiment intelligente où les servantes étaient la
boussole morale du monde et c'est à ce moment-là que
j'ai commencé à réaliser des projets télévisés,
motivés
ouais, je veux dire, tu sais  quand j'étais dans
Desperate Housewives, j'ai vraiment
pensé à mon avenir et à ce que je
voulais faire et j'avais l'impression que je
voulais contrôler davantage le
produit final, vous savez, quand vous êtes acteur,
vous y allez et vous
marchez sur une marque et  vous dites des lignes et
puis vous rentrez chez vous, vous n'avez pas vraiment grand-chose d'
autre, juste beaucoup d'autres choses que vous savez
à dire, vous ne pouvez pas vraiment choisir
qui est en face de vous ou quelle prise
ils utilisent ou éditent ou commercialisent et donc
vous'  Je suis à la merci de tant d'autres
personnes et donc j'étais comme non, je veux, je
veux avoir plus de contrôle sur ce qui
existe avec mon image et puis aussi je
voulais avoir l'opportunité de raconter différentes
histoires qui, je pense, vous savez,
sont vraiment brûlantes.  bon exemple de ce que j'ai, j'ai
eu l'occasion de définir à quoi ressemble un héros
Hollywood définit toujours à quoi
ressemblent les héros et ils ne nous ressemblent jamais,
ils ne ressemblent jamais à vous, vous connaissez
la communauté américano-mexicaine, ils ne
ressemblent jamais à Richard euh et donc je
pensais que vous  je sais que je veux, je veux me mettre
derrière la caméra et créer les histoires
et les images que je veux voir dans
les activités médiatiques, cela
fait partie du gala mondial des cadeaux que nous
organisons partout dans le monde, nous le faisons dans
neuf pays,
euh, mais nous  j'ai construit cette maison à Maruea
euh pour offrir des thérapies aux enfants qui
n'ont pas accès aux
thérapies dont ils ont besoin dans
la vie il y a toutes sortes de
pièces différentes dans la maison différentes activités
nous venons de commencer notre camp d'été donc
c'est là que je viens de prendre l'avion  je veux faire ça
pour être avec vous les gars mais en ce moment je suis
à Marbella en ce moment avec le camp d'été
pour les enfants Maria Bravo est un
ange euh qui
a créé cette initiative avec Alina
Peralta et moi et nous pensions juste que vous
saviez là-bas  Il y a tellement d'organisations caritatives incroyables
dans le monde et nous voulions relier
les points et relier les
efforts humanitaires partout dans le monde
pour apprendre les uns des autres et s'entraider,
vous savez et ça a juste
été le travail de ma vie, c'est
probablement le  la chose la plus importante
dans ma vie, c'est sûr
euh
oui oh oui exactement oui celui-ci
dit euh
euh parce que je le vaux bien
tu sais quoi euh non c'est tellement drôle
parce que j'ai l'impression que
tu connais les images qui sont diffusées, je veux
dire que c'est  une illusion et il faut un
village, c'est que je ne me réveille pas comme
ça,
euh, c'est pourquoi j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'être avec une marque comme L'Oréal a été une
telle bénédiction parce qu'ils ont toujours
été plus axés sur l'estime de soi et  comme
identifier votre estime de soi dans la vie dans
vos relations et votre travail,
euh, et donc pouvoir être avec une marque
comme celle-là, ce n'est pas vendre du
rouge à lèvres et de la couleur de cheveux, c'est hé,
vous savez que vous valez bien plus que
vous  réaliser dans votre vie et c'est donc moi,
j'ai grandi de cette façon parce que je n'ai pas
grandi comme une jolie,
ma mère
n'accordait vraiment pas beaucoup de valeur à
la beauté, donc je n'accordais pas beaucoup de
valeur et la beauté que j'apprécie  tu sais
toutes ces choses et j'apprécie que tu
saches où j'en suis avec ma relation
avec la beauté mais cela ne me définit pas et
je pense que
tu sais quand j'étais jeune, j'ai dit que je
serais la plus intelligente, d'accord, je le suis  pas la
jolie, mes sœurs étaient les jolies
euh et alors d'accord, je ne suis pas les jolies,
je vais être la plus intelligente ou j'ai
dit que je serai la plus drôle et j'ai
l'impression que c'est ma vie
c'est pour ça que je suis devenu acteur c'est pour ça que j'ai
mes maîtres et je suis dans
le milieu universitaire comme si j'avais l'impression que pour moi, euh,
ça m'a vraiment façonné euh en grandissant,
je n'ai pas joué autant de valeur dans ça, je dois le faire.
sois belle tu sais
ici
[Musique]
oh mon Dieu mon émission préférée appelle mes
asiatiques
j'ai les droits linguistiques
en espagnol je vais réaliser ça en espagnol j'espère que j'y
serai aussi euh
c'est juste ces tous ces
gens  sont tellement talentueux
euh c'est une très bonne idée, un
concept génial et c'est universel et Dieu Dieu
est comme l'un de mes êtres humains préférés,
je veux faire un film avec lui mais il
ne me rappellera pas merci s'il vous plaît
génial
euh
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
Kenji est incroyable
il a gagné The Voice et je pense que
ce soir-là, il est venu au Gala mondial des cadeaux
et il nous aide à collecter
des fonds pour les enfants du monde entier
depuis 10 ans, je veux dire, il a été
il était il était si mignon parce qu'il
était si jeune il était si jeune quand nous nous sommes
rencontrés et euh et il avait le béguin pour moi
il avait le béguin pour moi mais il était comme s'il
était un bébé euh mais il m'a chanté cette chanson
mais il a changé les mots en Appartement d'Eva
Longoria
oh oui, oh mon Dieu, attends très vite.
Ricky Martin est mon béguin pour les célébrités
sera toujours mon béguin pour les célébrités et
il est l'un de mes meilleurs amis, je l'aime
tellement mais
euh oh mon Dieu, j'ai rencontré  lui quand j'avais 14
ans, je faisais la queue pour un
autographe quand il était à Menudo et puis
plus tard dans la vie, je l'ai traqué quand je
suis devenu célèbre, je me disais oh nous allons
être amis,
ok, oh, as-tu une surprise, c'est  c'est
Ricky qui vient est-ce qu'il est là euh
trop vite j'ai parlé trop lentement je suis désolé oh
mon Dieu c'est lourd
ok oh la
Catalogne
est
oui merci beaucoup
j'aime ça j'aime tout le Sud il y
avait une autre ville qui était encore plus proche
mais nous y allions en voiture parce que je suis resté
à Figueras en fait, je n'étais pas à
Barcelone, j'étais à Figueras, qui est
essentiellement la France, tout le monde parle français
là-bas et euh, la frontière durait environ 45
minutes, je me suis tellement amusé et j'ai eu
beaucoup d'accès à  le beurre français qui était
très important la société
euh ce ne serait pas à Paris ce
serait peut-être dans le Nord ou le Sud j'ai
vraiment aimé le nord de la France j'aime
la Bretagne et la Normandie et dovil et euh
tu sais moi quand j'étais mariée à Tony
parce qu'il  il faisait partie de l'
équipe de France, nous devions toujours jouer dans ces petites
villes, il se moquait toujours de moi
parce que j'adorais Limoges, il était comme si on
ne pouvait pas aimer Limoges, je suis comme si j'adorais
Limoges,
tu sais où il avait un camp de basket
euh Léon j'aime Léon euh j'aime
euh bien sûr le sud je veux dire qui
n'aime pas le Sud
euh
étranger
[Musique] [
Rires]
reportage
oh je m'en sors bien [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]